Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Look at this video of a moving escalator.
Nothing too crazy going on, only the escalator
is moving. And I am wondering, would it be
possible to not record a video for this,
just an image, and have one of these amazing
new learning-based algorithms animate it?
Well, that is easier said than done. Look, this
is what was possible with a research work from
2 years ago, but the results are…well, what you
see here. So how about a method from one year ago?
This is the result. A great deal of improvement
- the water is not animated in this region,
and is generally all around the place, and we
still have a lot of artifacts around the fence.
And now, hold on to your papers, and
let’s see this new method…and…whoa!
Look at that! What an improvement!
Apparently, we can now give this one a still
image, and for the things that
should move, it makes them move.
It is still not perfect by any means, but
this is so much progress in just two years.
And there’s more! Get this, for the things
that shouldn’t move, it even imagines
how they should move. It works
on this building really well.
But it also imagines how my tie would move around.
Or my beard, which is not mine, by the way,
but was made by a different AI, or the windows.
Thank you very much for the authors of the paper
for generating these results only for us! And
this can lead to really cool artistic effects,
for instance, this moving brickwall, or
animating the stairs here. Loving it.
So, how does this work exactly? Does
it know what regions to animate?
No it doesn’t, and it shouldn’t. We can
specify that ourselves by using a brush
to highlight the region that we wish to see
animated, and we also have a little more
artistic control over the results by prescribing
a direction in which things should go.
And it appears to work on a really wide
variety of images, which is only one
of its most appealing features. Here
are some of my favorite results,
I particularly love the one with the
apple rotation here. Very impressive.
Now, let’s compare it to the previous method from
just one year ago, and let’s see what the numbers
say. Well, they say that the previous
one performs better on fluid elements
than the new one. My experience is that it
indeed works better on specialized cases,
like this fire texture, but on many water
images, they perform roughly equivalently.
Both are doing quite well. So,
is the new one really better?
Well, here comes the interesting part. When
presented with a diverse set of images,
look. There is no contest here - the previous
one creates no results, incorrect results,
or if it does something, the new technique
almost always comes out way better.
Not only that, but let’s see what the
execution time looks like for the new method.
How much do we have to wait
for these results? The one from
last year took 20 seconds per image and
required a big honking graphics card,
while the new one only needs your smartphone,
and runs in… what? Just one second. Loving it.
So, what images would you try with this
one? Let me know in the comments. Well,
in fact, you don’t need to just think about
what you would try, because you can try this
yourself. It has a mobile app, the link
is available in the video description,
make sure to let me know in the comments
below if you had some success with it!
Here comes the even more interesting part.
The previous method was using a learning-based
algorithm, while this one is a bona-fide,
almost completely handcrafted technique.
Partly because training neural networks
requires a great deal of training data,
and there are very few, if any training examples
for moving buildings and these other surreal
phenomena. Ingenious. Huge congratulations
to the authors for pulling this off!
Now, of course, not even this technique is
perfect, there are still cases where it does
not create appealing results, however,
since it only takes a second to compute,
we can easily retry with a different pixel mask
or direction and see if it does better. And just
imagine what we will be able to do two more
papers down the line. What a time to be alive!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!